his persona same thing that I go for is
like [ __ ] on the outside but he's a
softy on the inside yeah exactly
that like a gangster that doesn't do
crime wouldn't feel like a gangster
that's that's me and everybody else but
really nice to them that makes you feel
special they like a killer that kills
other people but he's soft and cuddly
yeah all right so this whole situation
with rents and pain rent and mortgages
these days please probably they're gonna
excuse it I don't know are they they're
gonna try can they give us immoral ways
of doing it what what what are you
saying what do you think I'm saying that
there's skeezius scumbag landlords
they'll be like oh you can't pay your
rent well I got another way for you to
pay your rent yes porno came true I bit
down again on my knees I would actually
many months is gonna cover dude I would
[ __ ] my landlord for free rent Benson my
Lords young would you would you be
bottom to do this in order to do this
you have to be bother you have to play
bottom cuz like she put sauce chopped
off she puts a strap-on on where's the
guy it's a guy it's a guy I think to put
yourself in a situation that some of
these are women that are experiencing
right now since it's a gun it's a common
thing I mean if it covers the whole 30
years mortgage [ __ ] yeah that's too much
bar why you gotta go month-to-month
every month a active these aren't
mortgage lenders these are landlords
that are renting you know all in this
property it's just rent or so the bank
comes over they go [ __ ] you hard the
banks [ __ ] hard like 30 years [ __ ] me
harder then
well you can't walk for five of them
what there's a 30 man bang bang one for
each year hmm what about like once a
month that's what they're at that's what
they're asking so what's happening right
now [ __ ] once a month some women and
typically the women that are being
targeted are low-income
immigrant they like poor girls well they
know that they can't take you
corner they got the power of fine people
as they can corner people that don't
much have much of a voice I don't know
sucks man
that does suck cuz why would you want it
for my amateur what do you mean just cuz
they're low-income though I mean they
don't have a phone no I mean like well
like I would much rather have a lady of
the night because she's a professional
if you were looking to be entertained
right as if you you know we're a king I
don't think these landlords are looking
for that kind of entertainment they want
flesh I think it's a power flat so it
sounds like hey I had this over you and
I'm gonna dominate you tonight and you
can't do [ __ ] that's sad yeah plus
there's not a lot of things that the
landlord's can do legally to make them
pay rent yeah during this time so
they're kind of just flexing their power
in other ways like bullying luckily you
could take with you in a jail yeah you
put some of these people are like let's
say if they're undocumented workers no
then you can't even report stuff like
yeah that's true oh that's so gross
because I just picture Consuela oh well
you can picture coz and I picture
Consuela I clean out any he's like you
clean now Consuela is out there I know
poor Consuela why this is Gail and her
son Dimitri and her son her son yes and
she received the text that wanna book
I'll be the landlord okay so you're
gonna stay all night what do you mean I
don't know if you meant to send that to
me
I did oh I don't understand what you
mean stay where stay with me tonight
get a shot of that I don't think I
understand what you're asking what do
you mean you don't want to I understand
I don't understand are you asking me in
a sexual way yes and that's how that
transpired but she looks like she has
her documents she's rude
look very straight from the border yeah
actually she was a bartender that lost
her job she was because she was in Maher
and the bars are closed yeah and she
also worked out of burlesque play
or less maybe he stereotyped dirt yeah
you already [ __ ] do this for money
yeah I get it
see that's what I met by professional
did he say anything about rent no well
this was in response to that she had
worked out a deal with him where she was
like hey I got fired from my jobs cuz
they're all shut down during this
pandemic I'm waiting for my stimulus
check can I hold off my April rent until
I received a stimulus check we're just
supposed to come in April and so he
agreed for that but then he kept
hounding her like where's the money
where's the money she's like I still
haven't gotten the stimulus check yet
and then that's when he was like well do
you want to stay all night then with me
and then oh and he has a wife what else
come back so our girlfriend he wants a
threesome I think he was an ex-wife is
that there's multiple examples of what's
happening with different what might be a
picky man but I she needs to pay me rent
I wouldn't take sex one night of sex
that's like free thought that's a mouse
but yeah he'll pay the rent
exactly that's what I'm saying but she's
offering to pay the money
she just needs to wait for the stimulus
tribe to come in but the cool thing is
she's still trying to pay right yeah
doesn't have to yeah she's out of it la
it's it's it's it's excusable but we
don't know what state they're in ah but
she had told him um like I have nowhere
else to go
please let me pay so it is a power yeah
I don't know man because I you know if
you think about it right if rent is
about a couple thousand bucks right
who's getting the real deal he's a Nancy
also he's old it doesn't matter that she
is you see a sexy old man
Molly 60 he's like in his sixties or
seventies a lot of sexy old guys no I'm
not
I mean this is wrong all around I think
it's disgusting I'm just trying to be
funny right now let's look at the
economics right separate your emotions
and yourself and the trauma that was as
a renter it would be so financially sick
I'm talking about $4,000 yeah one night
or even even if your rent was a thousand
dollars bro
that's [ __ ] high-class hooker eat
right what's the typical rate for a lady
at the night a couple hundred bucks
couple hundred bucks
that's pretty [ __ ] good you can also
you
just to open a can of worms no like what
like you give an inch they take a mile
whereas like he might just go straight
for the anal no well that could happen
or he's like he does they agree to this
but then he's like well actually I did
you a favor cuz I paid you know
basically three thousand dollars I think
I deserve more nights actually but
without what-have-you yeah you gotta you
gotta lay down the ground fathers you
take a mile and go okay then we'll do
three more nights and now you pay for my
car payment to you can you how about you
just marry me and pay for everything
might as well damn that's a business
transaction isn't in this transaction I
don't know I think if I put myself in
her shoes right I just saw this meme and
it was an old fat grandma in lingerie
getting out of bed and it said there
wasn't so bad now was it
here's your quarantine money I don't
know because if you're asking stuff like
this is obvious sex workers and like
like there's ones in Ireland Canada this
places all over the have like actual sex
workers are like legal yeah but they
always have to agree it's not that's a
business transaction for them it's like
they do it for that but when you're
right just asking something that's not
that that's pretty it's what you're
weird and it's alright it's alright ask
me can you make me a hamburger I'm like
do I look like a chef [ __ ] I
don't know how to do this I will watch
porn whereas two actors acting out this
scenario and that might turn me on but
if it actually happened to me in real
life I would be so [ __ ] scared out of
my mind
especially because this is her landlord
which means he this is her home knows
where she lives
he knows everything about ever to her
house go inside he can get in did she
report his ass she reported not to the
police I think she's trying to work your
case though right now I hope to report
to the police but no convictions have
been made no crime has actually been
reported so the names of the people
harassing the tent the landlord secret
anonymous the landlords are doing all
this stuff don't have names to this yet
so he's stupid they're anonymous yeah
but a lot of them like when they were
contacted by BuzzFeed which is this
they were all saying oh I was just
texting my wife or oh yeah I see
misunderstanding you mean sexually
he's stupid I did medicine it's you for
the girls if this happens to you get
everything as much you can't act and be
like so you're saying I can get free
rent at 5:00 sex with you and when they
say yes then you're you have a lot of
proofs yeah we can't go back and be like
but isn't there entrapment no if he
which if she reached out to him for the
nothing yeah but he's reaching out to
her offering what do you mean so just
yes so she has to have him defined
clearly what his intentions are
screencap and gall parties yeah help me
oh yeah it would help yeah you know what
sucks no a lot of the immigrants that
can't go to the police because they fear
deportation that's true they gotta go to
their local cartel boss that's why the
Chinese mafia came to be did you were
the police like so the whole like going
to your local like gang dealers or what
you call it cartel gang whatever those
people are so did you ever see the video
of the a lot a man getting robbed or
like the people are signing masks they
like egg them or like take their money
and [ __ ] no I just people they're going
around in those hoods and stuff I'm like
do it
oh let me buy like a few bats right so
go and they'll get the mass into like
egg dam or like so see that and and then
those dumbasses that film it and then
they post online the car the the the gay
members find the house and shoot up
their house that you wanna [ __ ] with our
local allotted men yeah so they were
doing that big as pranks and [ __ ] and I
thought it was funny it was like a few
black people that do that they would go
and like beat up like some people were
like they kicked up beautifully crazy
like when people like beat up like the
old Asian men and stuff yeah old Asian
ladies and then film it and then post it
online I saw that often criminy yeah
like you don't think it's funny and as a
praying it's I'm going to go anyway well
obviously that shit's like gonna blow up
yeah but it's like it's it's good that
they're getting the chest is for that
the loot is like knock out people in I
think it's a joke that sucks
same with people that abuse animals and
like put it online you think it's so
funny
and then they get this [ __ ] kicked out
of them and they don't even know what
happened yeah that's true yeah I just
came across an article where like some
kids like the the trapped a deer or
something like that and then what they
filmed themselves kicking the deer in
the face while the other one is standing
on its hind leg there which is last name
like they did one of those that's all
you heard yeah and they were just
keeping the deer in the face and got
their they got laid off pretty easily
too but that's some ham [ __ ] people
most people cruel funny I don't know
that got sad though no now I'm sad and I
usually try to laugh at everything by
sexual harassment was also sad it was I
was just trying my best to make it just
to make a different perspective add in
this article this guy just moved to LA I
think yeah he didn't get the job that he
came here for because everything got
shut down and his landlord was like
threatening to basically gang-rape him
every day that rent was late why is that
the solution joking well he has friends
that'll do it with them mm-hmm let's all
[ __ ] him together yeah they're willing
to [ __ ] risk Warren teen rules and
get sick yeah they're gathering in
groups of Penner all right a gang rape
you just found some kovat in some sperm
recently - they did yeah so you could
get you could transfer your STD now you
can transfer your [ __ ] shots yeah oh if
you get some sperm in the I well I mean
not a good guy they would have got it
from other ways yeah x2 like the making
out part maybe yeah yeah good
[Music]
[Music]